what are your best tips for writing  villain characters okay that's a great  question and my best tip is that you  cannot think of them as a villain you  can't judge the character you the writer  you have to be able to empathize with  that character find something about that  character that is like you too and then  you have to write that character like  they're making their case to God why  they should be allowed into heaven I  don't know if you've ever seen the first  movie I wrote was based on the first  play that I wrote A Few Good Men and you  probably know you can't handle the truth  uh that whole you can't handle the truth  scene from Nicholson in the courtroom  that is Nicholson's character making his  case to God like he should be allowed  into heaven even though he has committed  manslaughter so whether it's Mark  Zuckerberg the founder of Facebook or  Nicholson and A Few Good Men or anybody  else the audience can think of them as a  villain but not you